ablaze too large
too fierce
and moving too fast to contain
the oak fire started on friday near the
yosemite national park
and within days has grown into
california's largest active wildfire
it's so big that can be seen from space
i'm hoping that
they're able to get it out before it
damages anybody's homes but this doesn't
look good
but it's already ripping through
residential areas in mariposa county
thousands of hectares of forest have
been destroyed
the worst drought in decades has turned
the state into a tinderbox
people have been told to get out of the
path of the flames as soon as possible
they came by about 15-20 minutes ago and
told us that everybody's got to go about
4 o'clock the power went out and the
fire has been coming towards us faster
and faster
california's governor has declared a
state of emergency
evacuation orders has been issued for
more than 6 000 people living in the
sparsely populated area if you have time
it's great to pack some essential items
so medications important documents extra
clothing toiletries
hundreds of firefighters are struggling
to tame the flames
but it could be days before the blaze is
contained
priyanka gupta al jazeera